there is a universe of small molecules
hidden in plain sight The small
molecules are beautiful structures and
it allows us to think about really the
beauty of nature my name is Jason
Crawford and I'm a chemical biologist
I'm the director of The Institute of
biomolecular Design and discovery on the
west campus and our mission is to employ
chemical biology to solve problems in
human health
chemical biology by definition is
interdisciplinary the west campus its
mission is to promote interdisciplinary
science and I just love getting people
with different mindsets all in the same
room and thinking about a common goal we
focus on the basic science of cellular
physiology how do the molecules regulate
cellular processes and what is
fascinating is that if you look at any
cell whether it's a microbe or a human
tissue greater than 90 percent of the
molecules in those cells remain unknown
so a big part of our group is to parse
apart the jump from the molecules that
represent novel metabolic pathways and
if you can decode a novel metabolic
pathway this opens completely new doors
for a wide variety of directions
including pre-clinical drug development
so one of the guiding principles of our
lab is to decode these metabolic
pathways and understand how microbes can
alter human physiology
[Music]
we look at specific responses like how
do the microbes regulate inflammation
and how do they damage your DNA which
can be linked to colorectal cancer I try
to encourage my students to tackle
problems from multiple angles of course
give them feedback as we go but really
my job is to help them with the big
picture and push goals at a thematic
level chemical biology at Yale spans the
L West Campus The Faculty of Arts and
Sciences on Main Campus and the Yale
School of Medicine we try to collaborate
to promote the best science at Yale I'm
just truly fascinated by this area and I
can't imagine doing anything else with
my career
foreign
[Music]